hello and welcome to the airplane
national master fifth from south korea
right so Queens gambit all should be
fourth also line yep goes for Queens
gambit yeah against their goals and I
don't really have anything good i just
installed into an Enzo Indian main line
which always this interesting to play
but i don't really know this well
you
yeah just I mean I just play this with
doorman just develop pieces and hope
everything works out fine I don't know
any theoretical details really going to
be three spectra I don't know I don't
know it's just Bishop p123 can be an
idea here it's the most most standard
way of doing it I mean here I'm not
threatening all that much there with the
pressure on f6 and Queen h7 mate pretty
good pretty well coordinated but we'll
see I mean normally very often black
just takes on c3 with the bishop and
then place Queen to c 7 which is taking
a longer time they are longer think yeah
so here I think this idea own can be
played I assume
yeah how to do the sienna h4 can be
considered let's do it h5 can be an idea
of it it's them not necessarily
happening okay here in take d5 takes the
8h 5m but then also then also trades
trade a lot
[Music]
yeah I'm not sure it's really really not
sure about this I dislike the trade but
it gets aggressive climb Bishop f3
actually now you should get three that
trades too much for
but that's not a bad ending I can just
take it that's not bad and then take
here and then look to c 1 i'm getting on
the open file and rooks e7 is a very
awkward pin it's also h6 as an IBM yeah
maybe just still be 55 I mean the book
c-17 is not that dangerous yeah
definitely I can check on 38 a king g7
hmm now look see someone has generally
nice but he can take a free and click
into a fade and then I'm not okay need
to spend a move for a five but still it
doesn't do much right Jake and jump it
is not that great brilliant and I don't
like my pawn structure being completely
completely killed okay I'll take this
first look c7 takes takes a five we
should be forking an eight and I'm
getting nowhere maybe look to be seven I
cannot move the night yeah that's true
it's true okay the time is not good
chance my time management it wasn't
great really know this problem okay so
we should be fun King f8 I don't know
what I need to do this actually I can
also go here in merely so Knight f6 I
take I wonder where to put the bishop to
be prepared the bishop years of it
vulnerable
and maybe still here and now i can play
Bishop c6 not that that helps so much to
take takes their time money it's just
not going to be all that great now now
that didn't get get the best possible
outcome here
ok
isn't that good for white I get to d4
and then I'll make it better so I'm not
sure whatever I actually which now you
have to just play at 1.34 f3 ok
by the way ok I can be five why don't I
play king d 5 and still I'm still okay
with come on so yeah yeah feels cold ok
what did I see that it was good
checkmate wow I was really tough really
tough position I really thought I should
have something there I spend so much
time trying to find something yeah but
it seems it seems is defending him it
looks really a bit of awkward yet with
Luke c7 and everything but it isn't all
that convincing yeah yeah I thought it
just equal and then I surprised me with
rookie 5 which I thought should be good
so ok take f 4g 4s three
yeah and I know the engine is is showing
the wing and I just move I just take as
kind of useless to analyze with this
guide you have engine running I mean why
this just totally winning play don't
need an engineer is just do anything and
porn ending yes what's the point I just
win this position now that that's really
not interesting i mean the style of the
ending is another thing this is what is
the more indicate if there is a defense
there if he takes it may be king of
three at angles that doesn't work i go
to define a should win but take f7 at
the end I should have the history of the
key squares I think this should be a win
yeah engine is off + to add should
should be win it is totally winning it
is very dangerous to go into this ending
here from the black perspective to call
they have this chance of an outside
person is and also have the better King
so I wonder this is made something
[Music]
that's a drop pointing to the comp yeah
this is this is a cool defensive just
play for stalemate stalemate maybe have
six drawers then but that wasn't a
conclusive analysis huh amazing ok guys
thanks for watching